______________________________________________________________
This has been one of my favorite anime of
this year.
And as someone who gets off talking about
deep characters and complex story telling
for a living, I have to admit I'm a bit ashamed
of that.
That time I got reincarnated as a slime has
so many things that should irritate me, starting
with that stupid - fitting title.
The main character effortlessly gets more
and more powers, with practically no stakes.
There is a sea of side characters introduced,
that I can't and won't all care about, and
there is no clear overarching narrative that
seems to tie the story together.
Being a gourmet to the exquisite writing in
stories like One Piece, Jujutsu Kaisen or
Hunter x Hunter, I feel like I should be loathing
this piece of feel-good, escapist Isekai.
And yet I god damn love it.
I loved the first season and what's even worse,
I loved the second one even more.
So whether you love or hate him, let me tell
you why I think that Rimuru Tempest is such
a fantastic character and why the blue slime
makes for such a refreshing story for me.
By the way if you want this copy of the manga,
subscribe, as you already should be and I'll
pick one random comment to send this to.
Now that the anime is over I just have to
know what happens, so I'm gonna read the manga.
Now sadly, if you're not living in japan,
you probably cant just quickly get any manga
you like whenever you want.
Or can you?
I have partnered up with Bookwalker an online
bookstore and app for reading Manga & Light
Novels digitally worldwide.
They have a ridiculously awesome selection
of manga and light novels for you to explore.
Of course 'that time I got reincarnated as
slime' is part of their selection, and right
now with the end of season 2, they have a
special offer for you with up to 30% off the
manga including the entire set, coin back
and even some bonus items until the 18th of
October.
Link is in the description below, so once
we have discussed the story so far, make sure
to check it out!
There are two main things that make this anime
so great to me.
The set-up of the story overall as well as
its main character Rimuru Tempest.
The
big strength of this story, is that it doesn't
try to be clever or pretends to be something
it is not.
It doesn't try to preach any deep messages,
nor does it forcefully avert expectations
and tropes for the sake of it.
It doesn't go out of its way to be creative,
but simply follows the rules of good writing.
Characters are developed, the world is built
and everything that happens gets clean set-up
and foreshadowing.
It
doesn't try to break the rules, but follows
them with a lot of discipline.
In other words, the anime knows what it is
and what it is not.
And absurdly enough, I think that it's exactly
this authenticity alone that makes it already
stand out.
The premise is as simple as the title suggests.
A young man dies in our normal world and is
reborn as a slime in another world, only of
course that he gets ridiculous powers right
from the get-go.
Classic Isekai escapism.
From there on out, we basically follow our
slime hero, who shares our modern 21st century
perspective, as he discovers this new world,
gets stronger and stronger and starts building
a small nation.
Like, maybe it's just me, but that premise
kind of hits a nerve with me.
I've always loved strategic development games,
like Age of Empires, harvest moon or hell
even Minecraft.
Yes, getting strong is part of the fun, but
the real struggle is in building something
big.
So, as a kid, or even today sometimes, I like
to daydream about how it would be like to
be put into one of my favorite stories with
the best set of powers and how you could build
your own small comfortable place with it.
Does that make any sense?
And I think Fuse, the author of slime, I'm
just gonna call it slime from now on, it's
exactly what Fuse did when he created this
story.
Rimuru is not a shouen hero, who has to get
stronger, or even a hero like Saitama, who
needs to grow on the inside.
Rimuru already was a pretty decent leader
even as a human.
His junior seems to like and respect him,
and while his character does have a dark side
to it sometimes, I think it's nothing that
has to be changed.
Rimuru's character arc is not about growing
from a boy into a man or from a man into a
leader.
It's about growing from a leader into a visionary,
that can change or form a whole society.
So it's not about him getting stronger or
dealing with his emotions that we see, to
me it's about Rimuru growing to be the leader
not of a small team in his company, but that
of a whole nation.
Learning about diplomacy and infrastructure
and the politics of the world, with the necessary
power to back it up.
[Gazel saying that Rimuru is still naive]
That's what the story is about and why it's
so much fun.
It doesn't pretend to be anything more than
that.
A major factor in this context, at least to
me, is the fact that Rimuru is a grown man,
that also acts like a grown man.
He's a bit naive, but a quick learner and
most importantly, he is emotionally mature,
something that is so incredibly refreshing
for a main character.
And it gives the entire story a certain maturity
as well when it comes to his actions, decisions
and relationships with other characters.
Even the fan-service in the story, while undoubtedly
there, whole cow Shion can you walk with these,
it's not as over the top as I feared at the
beginning.
Plus it's surprisingly balanced between male
and female characters.
The main themes that were easy to pick out
for me include racial equality, helping others,
leading others, individual growth, positive
civilization growth, choosing one’s battles,
and being compassionate yet rational.
Those are all incredibly feel-good themes.
But even though I usually prefer darker stories,
it works for me, because the Anime compromises
this with some quite graphic imaging, but
more importantly a shift in focus between
the seasons.
Season 1 and 2 of slime felt very very coherent
when I first watched them, but now that the
season is over, I am shocked to say that this
is one of the rare cases where a season two
made the season one better.
Season 1 is all about getting familiar with
our main character, a ton of world-building
and the establishment of the nation in Yura
forest.
While this is a lot of fun to watch, to me
there were some big problems, should the story
have simply continued on like this.
In season one there are are no stakes for
Rimuru and no personal challenges.
Also, the focus on our slime made it absolutely
impossible to care for most, if any other
of the many characters thrown in with every
single season.
At the end, the village is mostly a faceless
blob.
Season 2 however, right off the bat I feel
did a fantastic job addressing all these potential
pitfalls.
Rimuru loosing loosing Shion and many other
of his friends, not only gives him his first
taste of reality and hardship, but also provides
some series development for his character,
that pushes the narrative forward.
He now has to deal with the fact, that the
3 rules he came up with on the fly in season
one, were hasty and unsustainable in the face
of all the ill intent coming toward his new
nation.
Overall the story and world of slime takes
on a darker shade, which immediately satisfied
people like me, who like some more complexity.
Bust because Rimuru is strong doesn't mean
he can protect everyone all the time, and
he starts handing off responsibility to more
and more of his followers.
This solves the other big issue with season
one.
Instead of endlessly adding more no-name characters
to the village, we get characterization for
all those form season one, which left me which
a much better connection to characters like
Benimaru, Gobta and Shion than in the first
season.
These characters now are not only powerful
themselves, but also act independently from
Rimuru.
And all the characters that DO get added,
all have fantastic or at least interesting
perosnalites.
Ramiris, Diabolo and my boy Veldra all are
very easy to relate to, even though we got
very little of them in season 1.
And by the way I cant believe they had Veldra
do a Kamehameha.
So, despite a very simple and text-book setup,
the story executes the rules of good storytelling
so well, that it's impossible for me not to
like it and be excited to see what comes next
for Rimuru and co.
I hope you want to watch a bit more, so check
out this video here next.
Thanks for watching.